body camera video from the Phoenix
Police Department shows what led up to a
deadly officer-involved shooting earlier
this month
hey Jackie come over here come over here
I got him down I got him down it
happened on November 2nd outside of
business in Maryvale Arizona a 9-1-1
call initially came in for a suspect
threatening a man with a gun hi I'm
ready see someone's pulling out a gun on
me the caller told dispatch the suspect
later identified as leonte Kirk was
yelling in the background and is this
guy white black Hispanic he's black he's
black he's wearing a red hoodie
and with the aleja and he's Young
that's him the caller also told dispatch
his uncle was recording the incident on
his cell phone did he point it at you
yes Mom he pointed it took it out and
everything my uncle's recorded and
everything
around
after the cell phone video is recorded
police say Kirk walked to a nearby strip
mall security video there catches Kirk
on camera walking into a store
investigators say he got in a fight with
another person inside the store after
they came out both men allegedly pulled
out guns
at this point the Phoenix Police
Department deployed officers via
helicopter an officer can be heard over
the radio saying there was an active
shooter situation uh these shoes that
people in the front of the store unit
number 23 we need more units to switch
over to Charlie 8 37th Avenue McDowell
we have an active shooter when officers
arrived on the scene three of them fired
shots at Kirk only two officers had
their body cameras turned on at the time
of the shooting in the first body camera
video shots can be heard shortly after
an officer arrives on scene
after that officers yelled at the man to
drop his weapon on the second body
camera video an officer arrives on the
scene and starts shooting he doesn't
appear to say anything before opening
fire
Kirk died on the scene as a result of
his injuries investigators later
determined the incident had not been an
active shooter situation saying there
was no evidence that Kirk or the other
man fired their weapons the names of the
officers involved in the shooting have
not yet been released but the Phoenix
Police Department says the deadly
shooting is under an internal and
external investigation it will also be
reviewed by the Maricopa County
Attorney's Office to ensure officers
followed the correct procedure for the
latest developments in this story and
all things True Crime stay with long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie